[Music]
I am a reformed marketer and I now work
in international development in October
I spent some time in the Democratic
Republic of Congo which is the largest
country in Africa in fact it's as large
as Western Europe but it only has 300
miles of paved roads the DRC is a
dangerous place in the past ten years
five million people have died due to a
war in the East but war isn't the only
reason that life is difficult in the DRC
there are many health issues as well in
fact the HIV prevalence rate is 1.3
percent among adults this might not
sound like a large number but in a
country with 76 million people it means
that there are nine hundred and thirty
thousand that are infected and due to
the poor infrastructure only 25 percent
of those are receiving the life-saving
drugs that they need
which is why in part donor agencies
provide condoms at low or no cost and so
while I was in the DRC I spent a lot of
time talking to people about condoms
including Damien Damien runs a hotel
outside of Kinshasa
it's a hotel that's only open until
midnight so it's not a place that you
stay but it is a place where sex workers
and their clients come now Damien knows
all about condoms but he doesn't sell
them he said there's just not demand
it's not surprising because only 3
percent of people in the DRC use condoms
Josef and Kristine who run a pharmacy
where they sell a number of these
condoms said despite the fact that donor
agencies provide them at low or no cost
and they have marketing campaigns that
go along with them their customers don't
buy the branded versions they like the
generics and as a marketer I found that
curious and so I started to look at what
the marketing looked like and it turns
out that there are three main messages
used by the donor agencies for these
condoms fear financing and fidelity they
named the condoms things like vivre to
live or trust they packaged it with the
red ribbon that reminds us of HIV
put it in boxes that remind you who paid
for them show pictures of your wife or
husband and tell you to protect them or
to act prudently now these are not the
kinds of things that someone is thinking
about just before they go get a condom
what is it that you think about just
before you got a condom sex and the
private companies that sell condoms in
these places they understand this their
marketing is slightly different the name
might not be much different but the
imagery sure is some brands are
aspirational and certainly the packaging
is incredibly provocative and this new
do you think that perhaps the donor
agencies had just missed out on a key
aspect of marketing understanding who is
the audience and for donor agencies
unfortunately the audience tends to be
people that aren't even in the country
they're working it's people back home
people that support their work people
like these but if what we're really
trying to do is stop the spread of HIV
we need to think about the customer the
people whose behavior needs to change
the couple's the young women the young
men whose lives depend on it and so the
lesson is this it doesn't really matter
what you're selling you just have to
think about who is your customer and
what are the messages that are going to
get them to change their behavior it
might just save their lives thank you
you
[Music]